[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم في دباسيل
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث او
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من الخرطوم حيث قالت
مصادر محليه للجزيره ان طائرات الجيش
السوداني قصفت تجمعات للدعم السريع في
احياء عده وسط العاصمه السودانيه
ننتقل الى نيويورك وتحديدا الى مبنى الامم
المتحده حيث حذر المتحدث باسم المنظمه
الامميه من تاثيرات محتمله للازمه في
النيجر على الوضع الانساني وسط ارقام
دوليه تشير الى معاناه الملايين من انعدام
الامن الغذائي
اما في بيروت هناك اعلان الحكومه
اللبنانيه وصول منصه الحفل المخصصه
للتنقيب عن الغاز الى المنطقه الاقتصاديه
الخالصه للبنان جنوبي البلاد
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
رغم تهديدات موسكو كيف تعلن مغادره اول
سفينه شحن ميناء اوديسا عبر ممر ملاحي
مؤقت على البحر الاسود وتؤكد قدرتها على
حمايه مياهها الاقليميه واشنطن تكشف عن
اتصالات مع الدول الحديثه لتحديد وتامين
مسارات بديله لتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه
عشيه اجتماعا لقاده الجيوش مجموعه اكواس
تقول ان الاجتماع سيضع الخطه النهائيه
لنشر القوات الاحتياط في النيجر باريس
تتمسك ببقاء القوات الفرنسيه في النيجر
وتؤكد رفضها الاعتراف بقرارات قاده
الانقلاب و واشنطن تؤكد عزمها افاده سفيره
جديده الى النيجر وتشدد على انها ستزاول
مهامها تيامي دون تقديم اوراق اعتمادها
لقاده الانقلاب
معارك ضاريه في الخرطوم وكل دوفان ودارفور
بعد يوم من اعلان مجلس السياده السوداني
خريطه طريق لانهاء الازمه الدعم السريع
يؤكد رفض المبادره ويحذر من انزلاق البلاد
لحرب اهليه والبيت الابيض يجدد دعوته
للطرفين لوقف القتال ويؤكد تكثيف الجهود
الدبلوماسيه للتوصل الى تسريع
وفي لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على
منصاتنا الرقميه ناقشنا المسارات المحتمله
للخروج من الازمه المحتمله السودانيه خروج
من الازمه في السودان في ضوء خريطه الطريق
التي اعلنها مالك عجار نائب رئيس مجلس
السياده السودانيه والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
التالي في رايكم الى اي درجه يمكن ان
تساهم خريطه الطريق التي اعلنها عقار في
الخروج من الازمه النتائج جاءت على النحو
التاء لقرابه 18% توقعوا ان تساهم خريطه
الطريق بدرجه كبيره في انهاء الصراع نحو
23% يرون ان المبادره ستساهم بدرجه محدوده
في انهاء الصراع بينما قالت 59% انه لا
فرص اطلاقا لانهاء الصراع عبر خريطه
الطريق
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيه
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
استعدادا لبدء حفل بئر استكشافيه للتنقيب
عن النفط والغاز وصول منصه حفر الى سواحل
لبنان
[موسيقى]
وصف الرئيس الاوكراني
اول سفينه شحن من ميناء اوديسا على البحر
الاسود رغم التهديدات الروسيه بانه خطوه
مهمه لحريه الملاحه البحريه قباله صباح
الاوكرانيا وفي الميدان قال رئيس الاداره
العسكريه في اوديسا ان روسيا شنت ليلا
هجومين بطائرات مسيره من نوع شاهد هجوم
اعتبرته واشنطن دليلا على ان موسكو لا
تعبا بالامن الغذائي العالمي وكشفت عن
اتصالات لتامين مسارات جديده لتصدير
الحبوب الاوكرانيه
منذ اعلان روسيا عدم تمديد العمل باتفاق
نقل الحبوب اصبح ساحه لتبادل الضربات
والاستهداف بين روسيا واوكرانيا حيث تعرض
ميناء اوديسا ومن اسماعيل ومنشاه تخزين
للحبوب اكثر من مره لهجمات روسيه بالمسيره
والصواريخ دمرت الاف الاطنان من الحبوب
وفق الروايه الاوكرانيه ومنشاه عسكريه وفق
روايه موسكو حرب السفن جعلت روسيا تعلن
قبل ايام تنفيذ قواتها انزالا على السفينه
شحن متجهه الى ميناء اسماعيل الاوكراني
وقالت ان سفينه الشحن تابعت مسارها نحو
الميناء بعد انتهاء التفتيش تلك حرب
استعراض في عرض البحر توازيها اخرى في
الموانئ هجومان جديدان بطائرات مسيره من
نوع شاهد قالت الاداره العسكريه الاقليميه
في اوديسا انهما استهدفت البنيه التحتيه
للموانئ والحبوب اذ سمع ذوي انفجارات قويه
في محيط ميناء اسماعيل على نهر الدانوب
مجددا حاول الع مهاجمه البنيه التحتيه
للموانئ الاوكرانيه في منطقه اوديسا
الليله الماضيه يستمر العدو بممارسه
ارهابه والاعيب الجوع وفعل كل ما يمكن
لاخراج اوكرانيا من اسواق الحبوب العالميه
وفيما يبدو تحديا اوكرانيا لخطوه روسيا
الصعيديه في البحر الاسود قال وزير البنيه
التحتيه الاوكراني ان السفينه تحمل اسماء
جوزيف شولت وترفع علم هونغ كونغ انطلقت
عبر الممر الانسانيه الذي حدثته كييف خارج
اتفاقيه نقل الحبوب لتصبح اول سفينه مدنيه
تبحر عبر هذا الممر المؤقت من والى موانئ
البحر الاسود وسيستخدم الممر وفق وزاره
البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه لاجلاء السفن
العالقه في موانئ
اوديساورسك خلال فتره مواصفته بالغزو
الروسي لكن تساؤلات تطرح بشان تامين سواحل
اوكرانيا ومرور هذه الشحنات وهذه السفن
لدينا مجموعه متنوعه من انظمه الصاروخيه
تبدا من صواريخ نبتون الاوكرانيه وتنتهي
بالانظمه الغربيه مثل نظام هاربون الذي
قدمه لنا الشركاء تغطي هذه المنظومات 100
ميل من سواحلنا اما بالنسبه للمناطق التي
تقع خارج هذا النطاق فلدينا وسائلنا
الخاصه لاستكمال وتنفيذ كل المهام الموكله
لنا
وقد يكون ضمن هذه الوسائل الخاصه ما كشفته
اداره امن الدوله الاوكرانيه عما قالت
انها مسيره بحريه مصنعه محليا هجمت خلال
الفتره الماضيه جسر القرن وسفينه هجوميه
برمائيه روسيه مناقله للنفط وقد لا تجد
كياف نفسها وحيده في مواجهه تاردات
الروسيه فقد نقلت عن مسؤولين قولهم ان
واشنطن تجري محادثات مع تركيا واوكرانيا
ودول اخرى لانشاء طرق بديله لتصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه واشارت الى ان الخطه تهدف
لضمان شحن الحبوب عبر نهر الدانوب والبحر
الاسود الى الموانئ القريبه من رومانيا
لتشحن الى وجهات اخرى ورفع قدره اوكرانيا
على التصدير الى اربعه ملايين طن من
الحبوب شهريا بحلول اكتوبر لكن واشنطن
وافق
تدرس كل الخيارات بما فيها العسكريه
لحمايه سفن الحبوب القادمه من والى هذه
الموانئ
[موسيقى]
في الحقيقه بكل تاكيد نعم هذا الخيار ممكن
ولكن السؤال الاكبر برايه هو لماذا نحن
بحاجه الى ذلك لماذا تقوم روسيا بعرقله
صادرات الحبوب من دوله ذات السياده الا
وهي اوكرانيا الى الدول الاخرى كيف لروسيا
الحرق لكي تقوم بذلك
الت
دخل امريكا الى الخيار العسكري لحمايه
السفن الى اين يمكن ان تنقل الصراع
لحظه لقد قاطعتني لقد قاطعتني وكنت احاول
ان اجيب عن سؤالك ان الروس ليس لديهم اي
حق قانونيه لعرقله صادرات الحبوب ولكنهم
قاموا بذلك وفي حال لم يتخذ الغرب خطوات
بالعمل مع تركيا واوكرانيا والحلفاء في
المنطقه الا اذا اخذ الغرب هذه الخطوات
سوف تستمر روسيا بهذه الانشطه غير
القانونيه اذا هناك سبل وطرق مختلفه يمكن
ان تستخدم تركيا تلعب دورا حيويا بالعمل
مع رومانيا وبلغاريا واعتقد ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يمكنها على الارجح ان
تقدم دعم الجوال ربما من خلال المسيرات
التي تحلق بالانطلاق من رومانيا هناك
سلسله من الخيرات التي يمكن ان تستخدم
ولكن الجميع ويجب ان يطرح السؤال من قبل
المشاهدين الكرام لماذا تقوم روسيا بعرقله
حركه الملاحه المرتبطه بالحبوب لديه من
اربع دقائق ونحن لا نتحدث عن دوافع روسيا
بل نتحدث عن الخيارات لدى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والغرب واوكرانيا ايضا
في حمايه سواحلها الناطق باسم قياده
البحريه الاوكرانيه يقول لدينا مجموعه
متنوعه من الصواريخ والانظمه الصاروخيه
تبدا بنبتون الصواريخ الاوكرانيه نبتون
وتنتهي بالصواريخ الغربيه
كهاربا هل اوكرانيا قادره على حمايه
سواحلها على حمايه امن سواحلها
بكل تاكيد باستطاعه اوكرانيا ان تحافظ على
امن سواخلها غير المحتله من قبل روسيا
روسيا لا تود ان تقترب من هذه الشواطئ
بسبب صواريخ نابتون وايضا المسيرات نعم
باستطاعتي اوكرانيا ان تحمي هذه المنطقه
ولكنه لا يمكنها ان تحمي كل منطقه البحر
الاسود ولذلك هي بحاجه الى مساعده هي
افضل ما يمكن ان تقوم به اوكرانيا هو ان
تجعل من شبه جزيره القرم غير امنه
للقوات الروسيه
والاسطولي البحري الروسي كي لا يتمكن من
تهديد السفن التي تحمل الحبوب والسفن
التجاريه الاخرى برايي هذه اكثر طرق
فعاليه بمساعده الغرب من خلال تقديم
الصواريخ بعيده المدى استهداف القرم
ويتعين على روسيا بالتالي ان تغادر
المنطقه هناك
موانئ تستهدف يستهدف في كل يوم شكرا لك
جنرال
القائد السابق للجيش الامريكي في اوروبا
كنت معنا عم نفرانكفورت
ينضم الينا حول نفس الموضوع من موسكو
باسيلي فاتيكا روف الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي سيد فاصيلي انطلقت اليوم اول
سفينه من ممر مؤقت كانت ترسو في اوديسا
الى حد الان لم تفتش من قبل الجانب الروسي
ما هو المعيار التي تعتمده روسيا في
السماح لسفينه بالخروج من عدمه او في
تفتيشها من عدمه
اولا
لدينا معلومات
وسائل محدده لا نعلن عنها ولم نعلن اننا
سوف نغرق كل السفن التي تتوجه لموانئ
اوكرانيا او الخارجه منها ولكن هذا حق
نبقيه لنا وقلنا اننا لنا الحق ان نفتش اي
باخره واذا ما لم نجد اي شيء ممنوع من
جانبنا عندها سنسمح للبواخر ان تذهب
للاماكن التي تستهدفها وهذا حق يبقى لدينا
ونحن نقوم بعمليه عسكريه خاصه وبالطبع لا
نستطيع ان نسمح لاي سفن تسير في البحر
الاسود ان تحمل الاسلحه او اي اشياء
ممنوعه اخرى ولدينا براهين انه اثناء
اتفاقيه نقل الحبوب كان هناك اجزاء
للاسلحه وذخيره كانت تنقل اثناء هذه
الاتفاقيه عن طريق البحر ولقد وجدنا اجزاء
لقنابل في سفن تركيا كانت تحاول ان تصل
الى بحر الزوفوه وجدنا هناك غرف سريه
وجدنا فيها
ولقد ثبتنا هذا اننا وجدنا متفجرات وهذا
شيء لن نسمح به ان تستخدم البحر لنقل
المواد الممنوعه على اننا في ظروف عسكريه
سيد فاصيله فيما تتحدثون انتم عن حق روسيا
في تفتيش هذه السفن والسيتو جورنال تنقل
عن واشنطن بانها تدرس كل الخيارات بما
فيها الخيار العسكري
هل جرائد الامريكيه قد تقول اي شيء ولكن
السياسيين الامريكيين قالوا لعده مرات
انهم لا يريدوا اي تواجه مباشر مع روسيا
لانهم يفهمون جيدا ان التوجه المباشر مع
دوله نوويه هذا طريق الى دمار العالم كله
اما بالنسبه للمسيره التي كان يتحدث عنها
الجنرال الامريكي اؤكد اننا قمنا باسقاط
مسيره امريكيه من نوع ريبر حاول ان يقوم
بضرر ضدنا
بتوجيه صواريخ روسيه
صواريخ اوكرانيه لاهداف روسيه ونحن لا
نسمح ان تقوم هذه الوسائل الامريكيه
بالتدخل في الحرب دون اي حياء انهم لن
يقوموا بافتعال نزاع نووي سيد فاصيلي يعني
تقللون من امكانيه ان تتدخل الولايات
المتحده عسكريا لحمايه السفن ولكن
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تعتبر ما تقوم
به موسكو
ابتزازا للعالم عبر تعريض الامن الغذائي
العالمي للخطر
نحن نعلم جيدا ان هناك نسب قليله وضئيله
من الحبوب التي كانت تنقل والتي كنا نصبر
بسببها في على هذا الاتفاق الغير عادل هذه
الحبوب كانت بنسب قليله تذهب للدول
الفقيره اما النسب الاكبر كانت تنقل للدول
الاوروبيه لا يجب عليهم ان يخدعوا ويغشوا
روسيا كنا نصبر على هذه الاتفاقيه ونقد
الواجبات التي اتخذوها على عاتقهم امامنا
لم يحترموا واجباتهم اما منى ولم ينفذوا
هذه الشروط دعونا ننسى هذا الاتفاق ونتوقف
عن خداع روسيا
وما يقوم به الامريكيين وكانهم هم زعماء
العالم وان لديهم الحق ان يقوموا بكل شيء
هذا شيء نفهمه جيدا وعليهم ان يتوقفوا عن
هذا نحن من سوف ندافع عن العالم شكرا لك
من موسكو فاسيلي فاتيكاروف الخبير العسكري
والاستراتيجي كنت معنا من موسكو
تمكن مراسل الجزيره من الوصول الى اقرب
نقطه مراقبه للقوات الروسيه على جبهه
افديفيكا بمقاطعه دونياسكا وتطل هذه
النقطه على المنطقه الصناعيه التي تعتبر
نقطه التماس الاولى بين القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه كما تبعد المنطقه قرابه 300
متر فقط عن موقع القوات الاوكرانيه
نحن في جبهه وفي احدى النقاط والخنادق
الموجوده في هذه الجبهه نحن الان ندخل الى
هذا الخندق الذي يقود بشكل مباشر الى اقرب
نقطه مراقبه للقوات الروسيه هنا في مراقبه
القوات الاوكرانيه والذي يمتد على مسافه
امتار وكذلك محفور تحت الارض لامتار من
اجل ضمان سلامه تحرك القوات الروسيه ويشكل
نقطه مهمه للقوات الروسيه في مراقبه
القوات الاوكرانيه
نحن نصل الان الى اخر نقطه في الخندق وهي
نقطه التماس المباشر على هذا الاتجاه حيث
تتواجد القوات الاوكرانيه المسافه الفاصله
ما بين هذا الخندق او هذا نقطه المراقبه
هذه بحواليه الى 300 متر تتواجد قوات
الاوكرانيه تعتبر نقطه تماس مباشره ما بين
هذه القوات القوات الروسيه تقول بانها
تطبقه وتحكم السيطره على هذا المكان وتحكم
سيطرته على تواجد القوات الاوكرانيه هذه
النقطه هي نقطه مهمه بالاضافه الى نقط
تشتغل عليها القوات الروسيه لغه الالتفاف
من الشمال والشمال الغربي من اجل اطباق
اطباق الطوق على كل منافذ الدعم التي
تتوصل بها
كمرحله اخيره لاجل السيطره على هذه
المدينه التي لا تزال لحد الساعه تحت
السيطره الاوكرانيه وتخضع لاسلطات
الاوكرانيه
نور الدين غير الجزيره
[موسيقى]
اجواء من الترقب في النيجر وجوارها قبل
ساعات من اجتماع في اكرر رؤساء اركان جيوش
دول المجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
اكواسا المجموعه سبقت المحادثات بالقول ان
المشاركين في الاجتماع سيضعون الخطه
النهائيه لنشر قوات الاحتياط في النيجره
يتزامن ذلك مع تاكيدات من النيامي بانفتاح
عقاده الانقلاب على الحواره من فرنسا جاء
التمسك ببقاء القوات الفرنسيه في النيجر
ومن الامم المتحده جاء التحذير ازمه
الانقلاب فاقمت انعدام الامن الغذائيه
الامر الواقع هذا مسلك في حكم النيجر
يحاولون تكريسه يقول قاده الانقلاب انهم
انما يخوضون عمليه انتقاليه
يحتاجون في سبيل ذلك لمزيد من الدعم في
الاقليم لسلطتهم المطوقه بالعقوبات
والتهديدات
من تشاد التي يزورها رئيس الوزراء المعين
من قبل الانقلابيين تنطلق رساله انفتاح
اخرى على الحوار
نحن في مسار انتقالي ومستعدون وشرحنا
منطلقات هذا المسار ومالاته واكدنا بقائنا
منفتحين على الحوار مع كل الاطراف لكننا
نؤكد على استقلال بلدنا فنحن بلد ذو سياده
ونؤكد على هذا الامر اي وقع لكلماته على
الجهود الاقليميه والدوليه لايجاد حل
لازمه النيجر لا شيء تغير في المشهد
المشطور بين فريق يرى ضروره اعتماد
الدبلوماسيه واخر يشتعل حماسه للتدخل
العسكري تدعو المنظمه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب
افريقيا اكواس قاده المجلس العسكري في
النيجر الى اعاده الوضع الدستوري من اجل
التركيز على امن البلاد
ومع ذلك ستجمع اكواس قاده جيوشها في غانا
لبحث ذلك الخيار انه اجتماعهم الاول منذ
اعلان الكتله تفعيل القوه الاحتياطيه غير
ان هذا التوجه ربما سيضعفه موقف الاتحاد
الافريقي الرافض بوضوح اللجوء للقوه ولان
منهج القوه محتمل لابطال التغيير غير
الدستوري اطلق مؤيدها لانقلاب في النيجر
مبادره لتجنيد متطوعين لقتال المحتمل دعما
للقوات المسلحه
ثمه ما يصعب التحسب منه
كتاثيرات انقلاب يوليو التي تمتد الى
اقاصي الحدود مع الجيران حيث تنعكس توترات
امنيه
وزاره الدفاع في النيجر اعلنت مقتل جنود
واصابه اخرين حين وقعت فرقه من قوات
النيجر المسلحه كانت تتحرك بين منطقتي
ضحيه
ارهابي عند اطراف بلده كوتوجو قرب الحدود
مع مالي
الوزاره اشارت الى ان الجنود المصابين تم
اجلاؤهم جميعا الى العاصمه
صحيح ان العنف المسلح في منطقه الساحل
جنوب الصحراء ليس بجديد لكنه يمثل تحديا
للحكومات المنبثقه عن الانقلابات في منطقه
ترزح في الاساس تحت وطاه حركات التمرد
المسلحه تلك التي تقول قوى خارجيه انها
شريكه في دحرها
الفرنسيون بالذات لا يعترفون بقرار قاده
الانقلاب في النيجر الذي الغى اتفاقيات
عسكريه معهم باريس تؤكد ان قواتها في
النيجر باقيه
انضموا الينا من يامي كاني كادوري هابي بو
رئيس حزب تعارض الديمقراطيين من اجل
الجمهوريه سيده كانيم
اجتماع الغد لقاده اركان الدول بالقول بان
هذا الاجتماع سيضع الخطط النهائيه لنشر
قوات الاحتياط في النيجر
شكرا على هذه الاستضافه الليله بالنسبه
الى هذا السؤال
المرتبط
بالمجموعه الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
سوف اجيب عن هذا الامر ولكن يجب ان نضع
الامور في سياقها كما تعرفون ان بلدنا
النيجر منذ العام 2011 يعاني من وضع معقد
مرتبط بالارهابي ومن وضع امنيا معقد
النيجر هو بلد فيه هشاشه وهو محاط بمنطقه
فيها ايضا توترات وما حصل في يوليو 2023
الانقلاب بقياده الجنرال يعني هو امر
دعمه الشعب النيجيري او شعب النيجر باكثر
من
95% نحن في النيجر هنا انتقلنا الى مرحله
جديده مع تعيين الحكومه
سيد كان من الواضح بان دول الاكواس لا
تنظر الى ما جرى في النيجر بنفس عين او
بنفس النظره التي تتحدثون عنها هي الى حد
الان لم تسحب الخيار العسكري عن الطاوله
وتقول بانها تضع الخطط النهائيه لنشر قوات
الاحتياط كيف يمكن مواجهه ذلك من قبل
المجلس
القاده الانقلابيين او السلطات الانقلابيه
الى امبورتان من الاهميه بمكان ان نذكر ان
نظره الدول الاخرى والمجموعه الاقتصاديه
لدول غرب افريقيا والجيوش الاخرى ليست
بالضروره الحقيقه ان النيجر هي دوله
مستقله لذلك رؤيه الشعب في النيجر هي
الاساسيه ولذلك بدات باجابه تلك ولكن
بالنسبه الى تدخل المجموعه الاقتصاديه
لدول غرب افريقيا على اي حال ما من توافق
اراء على هذا الامر وخصوصا ان الاتحاد
الافريقي لا يوافق على التدخل العسكري
بالاضافه الى عدد كبير من البلدان
وبالتالي ليس بالحل الجيد لبلد من مثل
النيجر يودون العوده الى اجراءات لاحلال
للنظام الديمقراطي اود ان اقول ان
الديمقراطيه لم تكن قائمه مع الرئيس
المعزول لم نكن في نظام ديمقراطي بل كنا
في نظام الاحاديا اوتوكراتي ديكتاتوري
وبالتالي عندما يقولون ان هذا النظام هو
نظام الديمقراطي ليس بالامر الدقيق
ونحن على مستوى شعب النيجر نامل ان
البلدان الاخرى التي نتشارك معها العضويه
في
ان تفهم هذه الخيرات لذلك الخيار العسكري
لا يمكنه ان ياتي بالحل الى هذه المشكلات
المهم هو الديمقراطي العقوبات تؤثر على
الشعب من الواضح ايضا بان فرنسا لا تفهم
او لا تتجاوب مع مطلب السلطه الانقلابيه
بالخروج من النيجر وتتمسك بوجودها هناك
اذا كيف يمكن مواجهه فرنسا او ما هي السبل
التي سيعتمدها
تعتمدها السلطات
اود ان اعيد التشديد على اهميه احترام
سياده النيجر العسكريون لديهم رد ونحن على
المستوى السياسي لدينا رد والشعب في
النيجر ايضا يعبر عن رايه بالنسبه الى
الموقف الفرنسي
هو معروف ولكن بالنسبه الينا الاساس هو
شعب النيجر العسكريون الذين استلموا زمام
السلطه اليوم
تخلوا عن هذه الاتفاقيات مع فرنسا ولكن
فرنسا لا تعترف
بسلطتهم بل تعترفوا بالنظام المعزول ولكن
يجب مراجعه الموقف الفرنسي من اجل التوصل
الى ارضيه وصل لحل وسط بين
العسكريين
وبين الحزب
السابق او الحزب الحاكم السابق اذا نحن في
النيجر انتقلنا الى مرحله جديده شكرا لك
كادوري حبيب رئيس حزب تعاقد الديمقراطيين
من اجل الجمهوريه
ينضم الينا من باريس الجنرال دومينيك
ترينكا المسؤول السابق للبعثه العسكريه
الفرنسيه لدى الامم المتحده جنرال استمعنا
من ضيفنا من اليامي يدعو فرنسا الى مراجعه
موقفها هل هذا وارد لدى فرنسا
في الحقيقه بالنسبه الى موقف فرنسا الموقف
الفرنسي واضح وهو يدعم المجموعه
الاقتصاديه لدول غرب افريقيا
وفرنسا ترفض الانقلاب الذي جرى منذ ثلاثه
اسابيع والضيف السابق قال ان 95% من الشعب
في النيجر يدعم هذا الانقلاب ولكن في
حقيقه الامر الاصوات من خلال الانتخابات
الديمقراطيه ادت الى انتخاب الرئيس بازوم
والانقلاب العسكري قاده جنرال عسكري لذلك
فرنسا قالت ان الحكومه المعينه حاليا هي
حكومه انقلابيه غير شرعيه غير قانونيه وهي
لا تعترف بشرعيه هذه الحكومه وهي تستند
الى موقف المجموعه الاقتصاديه الدول غرب
افريقيا الموقف بنسبه الى الاكواس صعب يوم
غد هناك حديث عن خيار العسكري ولكن الخيار
العسكري مرفوض من قبل الاتحاد الافريقي
الاكواس يشدد على اهميه التفاوض برايي لا
اتفق مع الضيف السابق مجموعه كبيره او عدد
كبير من شعب النيجر لا يوافق على ما يحصل
الان حتى مع وجود المعالق يعني موقف
الاكواس واضح تتحدثون عن نسبه معينه لن
ندخل في اطار النسب يعني ليس لدينا
احصاءات ولا لفرنسا ولا لي السلطات
الانقلابيه اي احصاءات عن مؤيد ومعارض
ولكن الواضح ان هنالك شريحه تتظاهر وتطالب
فرنسا بالخروج من النيجر
[موسيقى]
المسؤول السابق للبعثه العسكريه الفرنسيه
لدى الامم المتحده
نعود الى ملف النيجر لاحقا في الحصاد وفيه
يرصد مراسلنا عن قرب رغم امتلاكها
امكانيات زراعيه وثروات طبيعيه من بينها
اليورانيوم النيجر احد افقر بلدان العالم
[موسيقى]
الى السودان حيث تتواصل المعارك بين الجيش
والدعم السريع في مدن عده بعد يوم من
اعلان نائب رئيس مجلس السياده عن خريطه
طريق انهاء الازمه وقد اكد مستشار قائد
الدعم السريع رفض المبادره وحذر من انزلاق
البلاد لحرب اهليه حسب قوله
لا يبدو الطريق سالكا في السودان امام
خريطه الطريق التي اعلنتها الحكومه على
لسان مالك عقار نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
الانتقالي وتضمنت مقترحا لوقف فوري للقتال
وتدشين حوار شامل يؤسس لمرحله انتقاليه
فضلا عن استمرار تبادل القصف المدفعي
والصاروخي بين الجيش والدعم السريع في
الخرطوم وام درمان وكوردفان ودارفور فان
تصريحات القادمه من معسكر الدعم السريع
صبت في اتجاه المعاكس ولم تقدم اي تعاطي
جديا مع تلك الخطوه بل انها حذرات من مغبه
اتجاه البلاد نحو حرب اهليه شامله على
خلفيه الدعوات لتسليح المدنيين في
الولايات وحجزهم الى الخرطوم
اما المفاوضات والبحث عن حل سياسي فيجب ان
يمر حصرا بمنبر جده وتحت مظله المبادره
الامريكيه السعوديه نفس التي تم في دارفه
يستغفرون القبائل يحرضونهم بنفس الاساليب
الان هذا الجيش يتحول الى ميليشيا جديده
هذا هذه هي نفس الطريقه التي استخدمت في
دارفور هنا يتحدث الناس عن الزنجبيل
كماليشيا كيف يشاء بدات الطريقه التي
يمارسونها الان في الشرق لذات الطريقه
التي يمارسون الان في نهر النيل بدايه
الطريقه التي يمارسونها الان في الجزيره
وفي المناطق الاخرى هذه المساله يمكن ان
تعود الى حرب اهليه اذا لم تتم محاصر
مواقف تشيي بان الفجوه بين الطرفين لا
تزال عميقه فرغم تاكيد كليهما انه لا
مصلحه في استمرار الحرب وان البلاد واهلها
يدفعون ثمنا باهظا لذلك فان التباين حاضر
في كل التفاصيل الاخرى فحديث الحكومه عن
عمليه سياسيه شامله ستعقب انجاز خريطه
الطريق وتضم جميع القوى السياسيه المدنيه
المهتمه بتاسيس الدوله السودانيه يقابله
تمسك لدى الدعم السريع بالاتفاق الايطالي
بوصفه مرجعيه تؤسس للمرحله القادمه
اما دعوه الحكومه خصمها للقبول بمنطق انه
لا يمكن وجود جيشين في دوله واحده فيقابله
تشكيك من الدعم السريع في وجود جيش قومي
في السودان وتاكيد ان الحل يكمن في بناء
جيش وطني جديد على انقاض المؤسسات
العسكريه الحاليه
[تصفيق]
وقال منسقه للاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي جون كيربي ان
واشنطن منخرطه دبلوماسيا في السعاده ووقف
القتال في السودان واعتبر ان الوقت حان
منذ مده للفصلين العسكريين لالقاء اسلحتهم
والسماح بوصول المساعدات الانسانيه وتنفيذ
اراده الشعب وفق تعبيره
في محاوله الوقف العنف في السودان رغم
مغادره سفيرنا حان الوقت منذ مده الطرفين
لالقاء السلاح والسماحي بوصول المساعدات
الانسانيه والقيام بما يريده شعب السودان
وهو سلطه مدنيه خاضعه للمسائله هذا ما
يتوقعه الشعب السوداني ويستحقه وسنستمر في
التواصل مع الجانبين دبلوماسيا
ينضم الينا من ولايه نورس كارولينا
مستشار المبعوث الامريكي السابق الى
السودان ومسؤول شؤون افريقيا السابق في
البيت الابيض سيد كاميرون ما سمعناه من
منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي هل يحمل اي جديد هل
هنالك رؤيا واضحه لدى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه عن كيفيه او عن كيف يمكن دفع
الطرفين لالقاء اسلحتهم في السودان
كلا لا اعتقد ان هذا الموقف جديد وان
الفكره والرؤيه موجوده واشنطن ليس لديها
استراتيجيه واضحه بالنسبه الى حل نزاع في
السودان ونحن نرى ان الولات المتحده
الامريكيه لم تعر هذا الموضوع الانتباه
الذي يستحقه هناك ازمات مختلفه في القاره
الافريقيه تحصل على الانتباه بشكل اكبر
الانقلاب في النيجر او حتى النزاع في
اثيوبيا او في جمهوريه الكونغو
الديمقراطيه لذلك السودان لم يبقى بعد الى
مستوى الانتباه الذي يجب ان يعطى من قبل
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
دبلوماسيتها في القاره الافريقيه يبدو ان
واشنطن تركز على الاماكن الاخرى وتركز
بالنسبه الى السودان على محادثات جده
وتامل ان محادثات جده سوف تستانف وان تاخذ
على محمل الجد ولكن الا في حال فرضت
الولايات المتحده عقوبات او اتت في
مشاركين جدد او فرضت الشروط بنسبه او اذا
ما تغيرت الشروط بشكل جذريا في ميدان
المعركه لا ارى اي اختلاف في جده
بالمقارنه مع مكان عليه الوضع منذ شهرين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه تلوح
بالعقوبات ولكن ما الذي يؤخر فرض هذه
العقوبات من قبلها خاصه ان مسار جده متعثر
الى حد الان
اعتقد ان هذا السؤال هو سؤال وجيه بالفعل
لا اعرف ما الذي يؤخر العقوبات اعتقد ان
هناك جدل في واشنطن بالنسبه الى هذه
النقطه بعض الناس يرون انه اذا ما فرضنا
العقوبات الان بالنسبه الى الجرائم التي
ارتكبت في السودان الفرقه سوف يرفضون ان
يذهبوا الى محادثات جده ويستانفون الحوار
سوف يرفضون الحوار واخرون يرون ان
العقوبات سوف تحفز الطرفين
للمباحثات بالنسبه الى العقوبات يمكن ان
تفرض على الاشخاص سوف ياتون الى جده برايي
لان لانه برايي يودون ان يبذلوا الجهود
لرفعي العقوبات ولان الولايات المتحده لم
تفرض العقوبات لا تبدل الولايات المتحده
جاهده او جديه ومنخرطه اعتقد ان العقوبات
تحفز ولا تاتي بنتيجه عكسيه شكرا لك من
ولايه نورس كارولينا كاميرا هاتسن مستشار
المبعوث الامريكي السابق الى السودان
سابق في البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
قال المتحدث باسم الاسطول الخامس
الامريكيه يتم هوكنز ان هناك تهديدا
متزايدا على السفن في مضيق هرمز على وقع
عمليات الاعتراض الايرانيه بالقرب من
المضيق وفي تصريحات لوكاله الانباء
الفرنسيه قال هوكنز ان التركيز حاليا ينصب
على تعزيز الوجود الامريكي في الممر
البالغ الاهميه ومحيطه لضمان الامن
والاستقرار فيه وكانت واشنطن قد اعلنت
نقله ثلاثه الاف من جنودها الى قواعدها في
الخليج لتخفيف التوترات الناجمه عن
مضايقات ايران ومصادره السفن وافقه قولها
اعلنت السلطات في زامبيا مصادره طائره
خاصه كانت تحمل خمسه ملايين الف دولار
وخمسه مسدسات وسبائك تزين اكثر من 100
كيلوغرام من الذهب وقالت سلطات ان طائره
المستاجره انطلقت من القاهره وعلى متنها
ما وصفتها ببضائع خطره وهبطت في مطار
كنزكوندا الدولي
لوساكا واكدت احتجاز 10 اشخاص كانوا على
متن الطائره هم سته مصريين وهولندي
واسباني وزمبي ومواطن من لاتفيا وبعد
ساعات من الحادثه قالت السلطات انه بعد
تحليل معملي تبين ان المعادن المضبوطه لم
تكن ذهبا بل من النحاس والنيكل والقصدير
والزنك لكن بعد ذلك عاد المدير العام
للجنه مكافحه المخدرات في زامبيا ليقول
انه لا يمكن الجزم بطبيعه السبائك مؤكدا
ان التحقيقات في طبيعتها ما تزال جاريه
نجاحتها نقلت وكاله انباء الشرق الاوسط
عنا مصادر الرسميه مصريه قولها ان طائره
التي احتجزتها زامبيا ليست مصريه ولم تدخل
اجواء مصر واكدت المصادر ان طائره اخرى
غادرت مصر الى زامبيا كانت في رحله عبور
فقط وخضعت لاجراءات التفتيش المعتاده قبل
مغادرتها القاهره لكنها ليست الطائره او
نفس الطائره المحتجزه في زامبيا ونقلت
الوكاله عن المصادر الرسميه ان مصر تنسق
مع زامبيا للوقوف على حقيقه
وملابسات الواقعه
تزين النيجر مؤشرات التنميه عالميا حيث
تعد من افقر بلدان العالم رغم امتلاكها
ثروات طبيعيه من بينها اليورانيوم
وامكانيه زراعيه مهمه
اهل يامات في مواجهه الشرف العيش تكاد
تضيق عليهم البلاد رغم مساحتها الشاسعه
تتواصل فصول هذه الازمه منذ عقود ويدفع
غاليا ثمنها الصغار على وجه الخصوص ووصف
ارتفاع في اسعار السلع الاساسيه تعيشه
النيجر منذ سنوات تحذر منظمات غوت دوليه
مما ينتظر البلاد في قدم الايام تطورات لا
قبل وجيرانه في هذا الحي الواقعي على
اطراف العاصمه بما قد يكون لها متبعات فقد
انهكتهم موجات الجفاف والقت بهم
الاضطرابات الامنيه بعيدا عن مناطقهم
الزراعيه والرعويه في الغرب والشمال
بسبب الجفاف والمجاعه اضطررت الى بيع
مواشينا لعاشه اسره مكونه من سبعه افراد
الاسعار مرتفعه جدا بالنسبه لنا مثلا
يجد عملا اعيش منه منذ ضرب الجفاف منطقتنا
ونزحنا الى هنا الوضع صعب جدا حاليا
كما يعبر نهر النيجر بروافذه وتربته
الزراعيه الخصبه اراضي هذا البلد بطول 500
كيلومتر مورد مائي ومصدر محتمل لتحقيق
اكتفاء غذائي تبدو النيجر عاجزه عن تحقيقه
هذه الايام
يعمل بلدنا على ضمان امنه الغذائي مثل كل
البلدان بتوفير احتياطي احتياجاته على مدى
ثلاثه او اربعه اشهر والامر منوط بمستوى
المخزون ساعه الانقلاب فاذا كانت هذه
الاحتياطات حينها مرتفعه نوعا ما فاننا
سنستطيع الصمود لثلاثه اشهر اما اذا كانت
احتياطاتنا منخفضه فاننا سنشهد لا محاله
ندره وسترتفع الاسعار ارتفاعا كبيرا
ندره سيكتوي بلهي بها الفقراء والاكثر
هشاشه في هذه الديار يخشون وقد تلبدت سماء
النيجر بالازمات ان يستقبلوا اياما اقسى
مما استبروا قبل سنوات في النيجر يرزعه
غالب السكاني تحت وطاه ظروف اقتصاديه
ومعيشيه صعبه منذ عقود اوضاع يتوقع ان
تتفاقم اذا طال امد الازمه الراهنه التي
تمر بها البلاد باب الحرمان الجزيره
[موسيقى]
الى لبنان واخبار جديده يامل اللبنانيون
ان تساعد بلدهم في الخروج من ازمته
الاقتصاديه ولو بعد حين فما الجديد وزير
الاشغال العامه والنقل اللبناني علي حميه
اعلن اليوم وصول سفينه التنقيب عن النفط
والغاز في الرقعه البحريه او منطقه
الامتياز رقم تسعه الواقعه على بعد حوالي
120 كيلومترا من بيروت ياتي بدء التنقيب
قباله صباح اللبنان في اعقاب ابرام
اتفاقيه بوساطه امريكيه في العام الماضي
لترسيم الحدود البحريه بين لبنان واسرائيل
في منطقه غنيه بالنفط والغاز الطبيعي
بالبحر المتوسط تبلغ مساحتها 860 كيلومترا
مربعا يسمح لاتفاق للبنان بالبحث عن
ثرواته الغازيه التي لم تستكشف بعد في
الرقعه او المناطق البحريه رقم ثمانيه
وتسعه وعشره وايضا حقل قانا والتي تحمل
بحسب التقديرات ارقام مواعده وزير الطاقه
اللبنانيه الاسبق جبران باسيل كان قد قال
في عام 2012 ان المسحه الزلزاليه ثلاثيه
الابعاد كشف بان المياه الجنوبيه للبلاد
تحتوي على اثنين عشره تريليون قدم مكعبه
من الغاز الطبيعي وشهدت مناطق قباله
الساحل الشرقي للبحر المتوسط اكتشاف
احتياطات كبيره من الغاز خلال العقد
الماضي وازداد الاهتمام بهذه المناطق منذ
ان تسببت الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه في
تعطيل التدفقات ويامل لبنان ان تساعد
اكتشافات النفط والغاز في الخروج من ازمه
اقتصاديه ادت الى فقدان العمله المحليه
اكثر من 98% من قيمتها وتسببت ايضا في
انخفاض احتياطات النقد الاجنبي وزياده حده
انقطاع التيار الكهربائي وبحسب الخبراء
يحتاج لبنان من خمس الى ست سنوات قبل اول
استخراج للغاز في تم العثور على مكان
تجاريه صالحه العوائد من الثروه النفطيه
والغازيه اللبنانيه تختلف باختلاف المصادر
ويشير الخبراء الى صعوبه تحديد الحجم
الفعلي لهذه الثروه الا عبر الحفر ويقدر
الخبراء كميه الغاز في المياه الجنوبيه
بعشرات المليارات ففي حقل قناه الممتاز
جنوب الخط 23 اظهرت دراسات اجريت قبل عشر
سنوات ان هناك احتمالا لوجود غاز بينما
ذكرت وسائل اعلام ان الربح المحتمل من حق
القانه يبلغ 3 مليارات دولار اشارت
تقديرات اخرى سابقه الى ان الارباح
المحتمله قد تصل الى نحو 20 مليار دولار
ومن المقرر ان تنتهي عمليه التنقيب التي
تقدر تكلفتها بنحو 100 مليون دولار قبل
نهايه العام الحالي اي ان نتيجه الحفر
ستعرف خلال ثلاثه اشهر تقريبا حول هذا
الموضوع ينضم الينا من بيروت الدكتور شرب
السكاف الاكاديمي المختص في شؤون الغاز
والنفط دكتور اسكاف بدء التنقيب هل يعني
حكما وجود ثروات في هذه المنطقه
مساء الخير هلا لا يعني بدء التنقيب ان
لبنان قد اصبح بلدا نفطيا بل علينا ان
ننتظر يعني نتائج الحفر في البئر الاول في
رقم تسعه لكي يبنى على شيء مقتضاها انما
كما اشرت في التقرير الذي يعني نشر ان
المنطقه الجنوبيه من حوض المتوسط التي
يشارك لبنان يعني مجموعه ترسباتها او
مجموعه طبقاتها الترسبيه مع دول الجوار كل
كافه الدول المحيطه في لبنان قد وجدت
كميات غاز وعده فلماذا لا يوجد لبنان
فلماذا لا ايضا في لبنان لا يمكن ان نجد
غاز بكميات تجاريه فاذا كل التقديرات وكل
الدراسات الزلزاليه وكل دول الجوار قد
وجدت بالفعل كميات واعده من الغاز
وبالتالي من المنطق ومن المفترض ان يجد
ايضا لبنان كميات غاز خاصه في حقيقه اذا
بدات تنقيب اذا بدات تنقيب اليوم متى يمكن
ان نحصد النتائج
يعني مرحله التنقيب قد تمتد لحوالي شهرين
وبعد شهرين يعني هنالك موجب قانوني على
شركه توتال ان تبلغ وزاره الطاقه
اللبنانيه وهيئه اداره قطاع البترول في
لبنان حول نتائج هذا الحفر انما كما اشرت
سابقا كل المعطيات التي تملكها شركه توتال
وكل تحاليلها لطبقات التناسبيه وايضا لا
يجب ان لا ننسى ان توتال هي ايضا حاضره
بقوه في البحر القبرصي وايضا شركه ايني هي
التي كانت قد اكتشفت حقل ظهر في مصر حقل
ظهر هو من اكبر الحقول في شرق المتوسط
ويقدر طاقته ب 30 يعني ان شركه توتال
وشركه لديها الخبره الكافيه في في حوض شرق
المتوسط لكي فعلا تصل الى نتائج المرجوه
في في البحر اللبناني طيب دكتور وزير
الطاقه اللبنانيه الاسبق جبران باسيل كان
قد قال ان المسح الزلزالي ثلاثي الابعاد
كشف بان المياه الجنوبيه للبلاد تحتوي على
12 تريليون قدم مكعبه من الغاز الطبيعي هل
تبدو هذه الارقام واقعيه
يعني من الناحيه العلميه والتقنيه قبل بدء
التنقيب لا يمكن تاكيد اي رقم نحن نتحدث
من زاويه علميه بحته انما كل الدراسات
الزلزاليه هي دراسات واعده التي جرت هنالك
المنطقه الاقتصاديه الخالصه اللبنانيه قد
حصل فيها اكثر من ثمانيه دراسات زلزاليه
ثنائيه وثلاثيه الابعاد وبالتالي كل تلك
الدراسات تشير الى الى احتمال وجود كميات
واحده من الغاز انما من الناحيه العلميه
البحته لا يمكن تاكيد اي شيء قبل الحفر
ونحن نعلم ان نحفر على عمق يتجاوز ال 4000
متر يعني البئر الموعود الذي سيبدا الحفر
فيه في الاسبوع الثالث او الاسبوع الرابع
من شهر اب الحالي يعني سيتجاوز عمقه
الاربعه 200 متر فاذا على تلك على تلك هذه
الاعماق يصعب التنبؤ قبل فعلا الوصول الى
باطه الارض بمثل هذه الكميات انما تجدر
الاشاره ان حقل كاريش الذي تقدر فيه
التقاطه بحوالي 2. 3 او 2.59 هو حقل قريب
جدا او حقل يوازي حق القانون وبالتالي من
المرجح ومن المحتمل ان نجد كميات واحده من
الغاز كما هي الحال في حق الكريش الدكتور
شارب عاده ما هي العقبات التي تواجه
عمليات الحفر
يعني هنالك عقبات تقنيه
كنوعيه الطبقات الترسبيه او نوعيه الصخور
او او احداث قد تفاجئ يعني انفجار للغاز
او احداث او المشابه انما الكونسول المؤلف
للطاقه قد اجرى دراسه الاثر التي هي تحدد
بالضبط المعطيات التي ممكن ان تواجه او
الصعوبات التي ممكن ان تواجه عمليه الحفر
وبالتالي فان الكونسور قد احطاط واخذ في
الحسبان كافه المجريات التي ممكن ان تعرقل
عمليات هذه الحفر شكرا لك الدكتور شرب
الاسقاف الاكاديميه المتخصصه في شؤون
الغاز والنفط
[موسيقى]
الوقت ينفد امام المزارعين لتامين
المحاصيل التي ستطعمهم الامدادات الطبيه
شحيحه الوضع يخرج عن السيطره هذا ما جاء
في بيان مشترك لوكاله الامم المتحده عن
الوضع في السودان كثير من القتلى لم يتم
جمع رفاتهم او التعرف عليهم او دفنهم هي
اضافه للمشهد جاءت على لسان المتحدثه باسم
مفوض الامم المتحده السامي لحقوق الانسان
في افاده في جنافه وتشير تقديرات الامم
المتحده الى ان الامطار الموسميه التي
تزيد من مخاطر الاصابه بالامراض المنقوله
عن طريق المياه دمرت منازل ما يصل الى 13
الفا و500 شخص او الحقت اضرارا بها هي
تفاصيل تذكرنا دوما بضحايا الصراع اي صراع
وتكلفه اي صراع بغض النظر والتكلفه التي
يدفعها المدنيون جراء النزاعات عبر العالم
نتمنى السلامه للجميع ختام الحصاد شكرا
لكم على المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]